Oh, so if I push for me, you read it, you read it, you read it, are you waiting until
it registers? For some reason it doesn't register, really.
I'll wait for YouTube to prompt me to put ads on, that's when I know I can start talking
as soon as YouTube's like, do you want to put ads on? I'm like, no. No, I'm running
started with a stream, why would I want to put ads on? Good morning, good evening, good afternoon.
Is my fucking model crashed? Whoa! Excuse me, I saw that. OBS is currently eating 40%
OBS, hello? Whoa, whoa, whoa. Who or what? Nothing is open.
OBS, relax! 40%? The Binding of Sheevee, honestly. I do not know why I'm lagging.
Is there memory leak on the fucking main menu? Goddamn. Don't laugh that I'm not on a
win streak. Me, thank you for becoming a member. Dear Asical, thank you for redirecting into
my high snowberries, I don't know why OBS is melting. Whoa, you're breaking my model,
OBS, what the fuck? Holy shit, I think it's not an Isaac Data leak, it literally says
OBS bro, you need to calm down, who or what? I got the movie, I got the movie open for later,
I might have to delete the answer. I'm sure maybe that much of a video. Right, looks good bro,
I enter the news, I'll pretend that my model isn't lagging. So this game is called the
Binding of Isaac, is that a biblical reference? Yes it is, this game is about a 5 year old
boy called Isaac. Just close and reopen OBS, I don't know how to inform you, OBS is what
I'm streaming to you on, you're asking me to reset the stream, no chance. You should
reinstall it. So this is the Binding of Isaac and it is about a poor 5 year old boy who
experienced severe religious trauma and this poor boy has to go, I don't know the quickest,
basically long story short, he sees himself as a bad child, he sees himself as a part
of the devil and he chooses to lock himself in a chest in his room, all while his poor mother
and father are trying to find them, unfortunately his mother and father split, but these characters
you see on this main menu, Isaac, Magdalene, Cain, Judas, Eve, Samson, sorry Blue Baby,
Samson, Azazel, Lazarus, Eden, The Lost, Lilith, Keeper, Apollyon, The Forgotten, Bethany,
Jacob and Isu, these are all Isaac, my poor little boy Isaac is currently inside a chest
hallucinating due to the fact he is losing oxygen inside the chest. We are going to do
what's called an Eden run, Eden tokens you might notice, what did I purposefully plan
such an escapade on Eden tokens, no that's just how perfect the world is for us reeflings
and snow bears are hanging out too, thanks snow bears, I do appreciate you, so poor little
Isaac, we are going to do what's called an Eden run, Eden starts with two, statistically
two items, although you can start with an active item, a passive item and a trinket,
if you're really lucky, but it's completely random what you get, so we look at Lazarus
in comparison, we see Lazarus has three hearts, two speed and two damage, Eden is randomized
and it can produce quite a unique run, so we're going to try an Eden run, just normal,
I've not played, the last time I played actually was when the girls had just been picked, okay
so we have the pickaxe, our passive is the wafer, do you see that little tiny red circle
under the minimap, look I'm kissing it, see this little circle, thank you June for becoming
a member, I appreciate it, the wafer means that I take half health damage now, so this
is an incredibly lucky run, and my active item is the pickaxe, which can actually let
me get into secret rooms in this game, that circle will literally be, okay, so now I want
you to notice this detail, I'm going to write a review on this game, this is a 10 out of
10 game experience for me, so if we look at our stats on the left side, Isaac's base stats
are 1.0 for speed, that's a little boot with speak marks coming behind it, I always get
fire rate and tier size mixed up, but it's below average, our range isn't awful, but everything
is really not the best stat wise, we have a pretty decent tier rate honestly, not bad,
not bad at all, unfortunately, unfortunately, it could be better, what have we got, so this
is a passive unfortunately which will not give us anything other than money, now there
are shops in this game, oh see this is a perfect example of why our starting item is such a
good lucky pull, we normally would need a bomb in order to access this, so because we
already have a soul heart on our persons, we are going to pick it up because we will take
soul heart damage over red heart damage, I already missed the rock because our tinted
rocks also wasn't paying attention, oh wait, am I going to, no, sorry, sorry, wait what
do you mean I missed our rock, motherfucker, right, there's also a thing called tinted
rocks in this game as well, whoa, right, we've got BFF, that's pretty decent, and the item
room, oh for fuck's sake, right, hold on, hold on, embarrassing, embarrassing, here's
me trying to be like, oh this is how this game works, and of course I missed something
really obvious, oh for dear eye, I was like eh, there's no rock back here, oh that's so
obvious, okay so there's also a thing called tinted rocks, when you destroy them you have
the odds of getting one soul heart are pretty high, now you also can spawn trap doors, and
depending on if they have a ladder or not, it would actually be kind of nice to get BFF
in case we pick up a familiar, the odds of receiving a familiar in the game are pretty
high, so these stone guys aren't real enemies, but I would like you to take a note, look at
our body, and then look at the body of the enemies, okay, okay he may have just walked
into the fire, all the enemies are poor little Isaac, and all the rooms are Isaac in the
chest, look at the shape of this room, now I know you might be saying absolute schizophrenic
gameplay, what do you mean the room, the room's rectangular, it's one of the most common
shapes, and that doesn't make sense because look at the room you're going up ahead, look,
they had to do some stuff, okay just relax, we're getting the pickaxe out, it's very safe
to have the pickaxe, but everything relates to poor little Isaac being in a chest, now
I knew the secret room was most likely there due to this long room especially spawning in
on a flat floor, so this is called a bomb beggar, you can't, fantastic, fantastic, we are finding
so many soul hearts, which I will tell you exactly why in the next level is very important
to get these soul hearts, so this is a bomb beggar, an exchange of la bomba, he can potentially
give us a payout of keys, of money, so if you wanted to do a cheeky exchange rate you most
certainly can, but the original game, are you going devil, no, I am an angel player,
now unfortunately me, thank goodness I was actually going to, that went really well,
oh right, so sometimes rooms can spawn spiders that weren't originally there, if you don't
want to, I have watched so many people play this game and I actually had no idea what's
going on until now, allow me to explain, I started this game this year and it's just
absolutely fantastic, so we're not going to carry this pill, but notice how it says
question mark or unidentified pill, it could potentially be a good pill, it could potentially
be a bad pill, I personally am not risking any stats down at the moment because we are
needing a bit of health and this card, the two of hearts, not any tyrant cards, the two
of hearts, doubles Isaac's red hearts, well that's actually pretty terrible, in all actuality
that's pretty terrible, we might get a machine, so we've discovered those two secret rooms,
so there's a secret room, a super secret room and there's actually an ultra secret room
which we do not have access to, nor can I guess where it's located on the map, we could
go inside, this is what's called the cursed room, so the reason why we're going to go
in the cursed room, you notice those teeth marks around it, danger, danger, not good,
however we have the wafer which means we will take half health, so for the sacrifice of
one soul heart, we might be able to get something better, so we're going to risk it, we're going
to risk it, we have received two black hearts, these have a necronomic effect, I'm an idiot
there's a penny back in that room, we are going to bomb up my donation machine, you can
see it's a bit low, so necro hearts are, we are going to pick up BFF, oh ok, we're not
going to pick up BFF against the sadness of my heart because the likelihood of us doing
it, we do have piggy banks, so we're going to get members access which opens up a, oh
did I just freaking buy a pill, I might as well take it then right, what is it, what's
the pill, ok it was actually a tears up, ok so that means we fire more tears, that was
so lucky, we're not doing BFF, however we now have access to a secret shop, no it will
be a ridiculous price and unfortunately it's very unlikely we'll be able to, again with
the spiders, it's very likely, we're going to have to raise our economy, however thanks
to the pickaxe, we can destroy, honestly we might as well just destroy, oh wait hold on
we're not even done the boss fight yet, ok first boss fight, now you might notice those
two symbols, bottom left on the statistics look I'm getting closer to them, see these,
this is devil deal and angel deal chance, you do not spawn devil deal or angel on the
first floor, doesn't matter, you can't get it, the exceptions are if you have a joker
card, you spawn in with goat head for example, but for the first floor of the game, you ain't
getting nothing, you ain't getting nothing, sit down ok, was the same colour of the pill
the one you skipped, let's find it, no, so this is not a tears up or else it would identify
itself as a tears up because we now know what type of pill that is, ok, so again we've
discovered both rooms, we have actually purchased a secret member door, we do unfortunately
have yet to receive the gurglings, right, three of them, this is terrible streamer luck,
back off, stay back, on guard, on guard, ok so we just had a necronomic effect which is
ok, that was terrible luck, ok we do receive a speed upgrade which is good, we are now
above speed, the base game speed so we'll be able to kind of dodge more enemies, that
was terrible luck three of them, but anyway we now have enough speed to get away from
the most average enemy to make a bit of a room between us, ok, but we did it, we destroyed,
oh poor Isaac, he got jumpscared on the toilet, Isaac is not, so you'll now notice on bottom
left we now have 100% chance of a devil deal, if we were to receive any red heart damage
we have two red hearts, a lot of souls and we necro as well on top, ok, sorry I'm going
to drink my tea, before anyone that does know this game, no we're not doing boss rush, a
kibiar's, unless we get Miss Bomba, I forget her name sometimes, I'm going to sit with
my tea, but yes this game is absolutely fantastic, unfortunately for level 2 we got what's called
the burning base mint, if you look on the walls you'll notice there's fire but what
means is that there's also a few enemies on this floor, Mama Mega, there you go Miss Mega,
I was close enough, Mama Mega is the exception that'll let you into the boss rush room, but
no we're not going to do any alt pathing, we're not going to do any of that, I'm just going
to show the basics, we're going to hopefully have a successful run, I would very much enjoy
an item that does some, is that a cat hair in my tea, I swear Gimli, is that a cat hair
in my tea, hold on a minute, no oh my god it's just schizophrenia, it's just schizophrenia
I'm sorry, right hold on, no we're not doing hush either but yes this game is a 10 out
of 10, it is absolute chaos the first time you play it and I kid you not it takes hours
upon hours to even comprehend what you're doing, you might think oh Isaac, Binding of
Isaac that we game, where that cute little pixel boy runs around, absolutely not, this
game is horrific but I will point out we picked up the bell and look at our stomach, we have
a bell on us now, as you pick up items Isaac will reflect those items, that's why we're
currently glowing blue right now, that is because of the wafer, fantastic angel item
that we spawned in, it's just schizophrenia, I relate to that on a personal level, don't
you have to unlock the burned rooms too, yes I forgotten how I unlocked it but yeah, Binding
of Isaac players be like I have 4000, I'm still a rookie, yes so this game, if it is
a game for you or might be a game for you, it becomes multiplayer in November which obviously
you know exactly what that means, we flings, we're all going to be playing it together,
the lobby sizes can go up to 4, so basically we're going to have quite a few endurance
marathons and multiplayer together, Strone is truly the Binding of Isaac Warmaster, I
wish we could do an omega run, the likelihood of an omega run is absolutely minuscule unless
our secret room, actually speaking of secret room, how cool would it have been if it was
in there though, imagine if it was, sometimes the secret room spawns directly in the room
you spawn in, well it is a lovely game and I can't wait to play with you in November
if you are an Isaac player, I do not have all unlocks, I do not have, I don't even have
a second file, you're supposed to have all unlocks on a file 2 and 3, I don't even have
them on one, but the items you receive from the treasure room, from the shop etc will
shape your run as well as the angel and devil deals will come in clutch, now originally
I said I would do angel deals but I have to admit with our high HP right now I'm a bit
tempted, I have so many arrows in the game I still don't know how to spawn the angel
room, if you take, if you walk inside a devil deal, you are not allowed an angel room, if
you walk inside it, if you ignore it and go down into the next level your angel room will
take over your devil room percentage, you can also raise it by going on the sacrifice
room, or I think it's called the sack shuffle to some people, don't give in to temptation,
no I want to show you the power of angel deals, I also want to show you something critical
you must do if you want to raise your angel deals, I will also do it in greed mode, I'm
going to play one Eden run and then we're going to play one Lilith greed mode, just
to talk through the mode, greed mode Lilith is the easiest character you can play by
far due to her treasure blocks, I've almost finished my tea I promise, I promise, Lilith
Seals so okay I'm going to get a wee drink of water as well, I can open it this time
without my wrist cracking, you're allowed to visit but don't take anything, I haven't
found that unless I'm being daft, I always find ignoring it is the way it goes, right
this room is smaller on her little map, can you see her little map on the top right, so
likely there's not too many enemies in here, so we are just going to go this way but yeah
there we go, and now he shoots in a diagonal at diagonal, up at downy 4, these red poops
cannot be destroyed and you do not get items from them, do not be fooled, do not be fooled
they are not good, but you will get, you will encounter enemies that like you can't reach
or you can't do anything with, okay no, no I'm not energy, if I could get a spoon spender,
if I could get a spoon spender that would be great, so we only have one key right now,
so I'm actually going to pass on the shop, we only have three coins so there's no point,
I'm going to look for a tinted rock but there's no tinted rock in this room, well I have,
Jesus, getting my hammer out for this one, get down, relax, I only just got in the room,
there is a chance, there you go, I was going to say, there is a very high chance your secret
room is actually right before the boss, it's so common, curious, I do not have, your luck
percentage doesn't affect machines like that, apparently, but I don't know how much I believe
that, peeking the first devil deal makes you next 50-50, but if you ignore then it locks in,
okay that makes sense, okay we're gonna get the fucking pickaxe out again, geez, we keep
getting rooms that are like really bad, right, again we only have one key so we're going all out
on the item room, surely, surely it's a good item, it's an active item, yeah, okay, I don't need
an active item, maybe we can get a black rune, don't want to, oh, yep, okay, sorry, I saw that
come in halfway across the room, I was like, I do not have the speed for these guys, okay,
one more, one more, one more, those Isaacs have a bomb in their head and they chase you down,
which isn't very nice, but is that gonna stop them, no, so we actually are gonna bomb for this one,
the reason because is we can actually get money from the pops, like that, so again, spider spawned,
but we're just gonna leave the room, don't even have to deal with them, as for the secret room,
okay it's here, sorry, I have a bit of sense through the classic Isaac gaming experience,
but we've discovered both our rooms, again we don't actually have any keys to access the shop,
nor do we have enough for the premium item, sometimes items can be for sale in the shop, but
we don't have a key, so we can't go in, however, we could bomb this fortune teller machine up for
a chance, for a chance of a coin or a soul heart, but hey, I'd rather not gamble like that, I have
found, oh, Jukka flies very easy enemy, oh my god, it's a big fly though, relax, I don't have the
damage for all of this, relax, okay it's fine, it's fine, Jukka is very weak to bombs actually,
so I'm just gonna put one, Jukka is very weak to bombs, so I'm just gonna, there we go, there we
go, there we go, I was gonna say something, I'm just gonna put one down, he's very weak to bombs,
so again, the devil deal has spawned, but we say no, we have received a range upgrade, and was that
tier size, I wasn't paying attention, is this after birth, this is all of them, I've completely
forgotten, so again, we don't have a key, we're gonna have to say sorry shop, and the active item
was a lobomba, again, apologies lobomba, but you do not do anything for us, there's no tinted rock in
this room as far as I can see, well, time to go next, we're saying no thank you to El Diablo,
you could visit the curse room, I could, but because I had necronomic hearts, I like them as
a lifeline, yeah, not this time, right, let's get toot, oh, I'm getting so distracted, sorry I was
gonna talk about this flat wall, hold on, hold on, are you trolling me right now, right, notice how
flat this wall is here, there's nothing against, oh for fuck's sake, of course it's not even the
secret room, I was gonna be like, if you ever enter a room and there's like a really flat wall,
that was absolutely terrible, hold on, I need MLG this right now, okay boom, normally the,
oh for fuck's sake, I hate these guys as well, yeah, it's even they do like a triple spray, like
bro, you don't even have the, you don't even have three familiar transformation, I've forgotten what
it's called, you can't hurt him unless he's shown his wee neck, thankfully, oh wait, hold on, this
wall is flat, okay, there we go, this wall is flat, so I came to, leave me alone, Mr. Spider, I'm so
bad against spiders, literally it's the only thing that freaking kills me in this game, now we have
a bit of a gamble, whoa, what did you do, a sack, oh well, we have a bit of a gamble, right, so look
at my angel percentage, it says 33.8%, we are going to bomb this corpse in here, and look, it went up by
2.5%, so when you bomb it, I guess previous Isaac bodies is really the only way to see it, we're
going to come back, we're going to come back to that room, let him get up, let him get up, although
actually you can get in golden chests, you actually can get a few items in a secret room from a
gold chest, so we may, I don't know, I don't want to miss the shop, we have really good economy and
we have a member's card, which means we have access to, oh right, there we go, boom, boom, boom,
let's see what's in here, key, we got our money, we got a key back, there we go, we have a tier
upgrade and range and three random hearts, and we get very lucky with an necronomic and a soul,
because we have that soul heart, I am happy to go back into the curse room, I'm going to sacrifice
the soul heart to see what's at curse, are you fucking kidding me, it's just more spiders,
um, now unfortunately our damage is low, which means that we are having to lick these enemies
for quite a few moments, unfortunately he splits into two spiders, which I'm not looking forward
to, there you go, um, now we, this does count as an active reward, like an active item reward,
doing a room like this, but that is a shame that we didn't get a payoff, but hey, what the heck,
uh, what a strange room, right okay, we've got super sloth, which isn't ideal with our freaking
terribly low damage, and all these, wow, these things are absolutely, oh dear, oh my god,
oh I need to start out spiders, please, no please, please, no what the heck, he can, stop, stop,
stop, this is awful, stop, this is truly awful, please, stop, stop, stop, or my damn right,
you're giving me a pedestal item, that couldn't have gone any worse, that's actually not that bad,
right, if, okay, okay, we've got a black rune, um, we've also picked up a trinket that lets us,
that was the worst, I couldn't have made that any worse if I tried, um, this is, that's why I'm
saying we are very low damage, things are able to punish us very harshly, I'm just gonna check
there's no tinted rock in here, no, not as far as my elf eyes can see, that was awful, and of course,
please, I want spoon bender, so I don't actually have to aim, that would be great,
one spoon bender, or familiar spoon bender, I'll take it, okay, there we go, now we do have a
chess, which we've got two hearts from, please,
um, right, so because we picked up the trinket on this floor, we actually don't have the respawn
box, which is a shame, we are gonna take ice baby, we might be able to get conjoined three,
now if we end up getting conjoined, this is where we go, draft, the game could have,
um, the game could have, it's icy, oh it's icy actually, hold on, let's see if we can pick up
an item for everyone, oh okay, Miss Dolly's gonna be sheebie, because sheebie has nice blonde hair,
and then the red bow will be the red at the bottom of her hair,
Emi is something evil, we don't have anything evil for Emi yet, but we're gonna pick it up,
we're gonna hopefully get conjoined, normally you get a few more, see, oh my gosh, right,
we need to stop taking damage, I ain't joking the way for saving us, re-factor, thank you very much
for coming to member, so once an enemy's frozen you can actually use them to attack, um, I don't
know where the secret room is, other than that one we're at, lawyer, I really don't like long
room spawning in because I, oh they're bombs, the, the spiders are bombs, wow, are you joking that
tiny wee thing, ah we're actually losing, the raw embarrassment, whoa,
birthright and steam sale, steam sale lowers everything by half, birthright gives us three
items to choose from, uh we've got dead bird, we can put our health up and shot speed up over dead
bird, I don't know, dead bird might help us though, if I'm completely messing up, I mean
there's no point in doing duality, oh is there though, no because we're going for angel,
I, I mean shot speed going up or a bird that comes in attacks every time I take damage,
wait I get electric at both, spawns both in devil and angel room if either,
entering one makes the other disappear, I don't know, I,
dead bird's gonna fm up though for me which is kind of what I'm needing, not gonna lie, not gonna lie,
I'm kind of needing a bit of dead bird, but I'm needing health as well, right, fuck it dead bird,
Eve come on in, right let's see what's going on down here in the basement, hello,
hello, this soul, grants an aura that repels the projectiles, I know there's red key,
um this is such a good batch as well because this would give me conjoined part two of three,
I'm going for repel,
I'm going to see if we can come up with the money,
right okay okay we can get conjoined part two, okay okay conjoined part two, oh my god look at it,
oh he's got we nail, we, that red key is pretty special,
I'm gonna see if we can get a money off this keeper as well, no didoms,
he does a veep attack this fly so you can kind of ignore him, are we that,
we got a dame, wait oh we don't have enough though, wait,
okay there we go, I was going to say the odds, and another soul, wow, wowie we wow,
we're actually doing very lucky, yeah how do you say lucky, lucky, lucky, even though I suck at
the fates, but we're actually doing pretty decent, why are you spawning two enemies,
this is so unfair and I got hit, that's right, no get him get me, get him get me, beat him up,
hold it, go get me go, go get me go, wow, let's go get me, you did it, and we got PJs,
now we're full health, wow that's actually pretty insane, right a special fact with the angel deals,
health up and damage, okay this if you want to continually get angel deals you have to do this
thing that makes no sense, you have to attack this angel and they will drop a key piece which
which raises your chances of getting more angel deals, don't don't ask to make sense of it,
it makes no sense, literally attack an angel and oh I do have a mod that lets me know when they're
laser fire because I have a few mods, I have laser fire mod, I have mum stomp because I can never
see when she's gonna stomp down on me, I'm absolutely rubbish at it, truly rubbish, so angels
can actually, I forget his name, but he can actually hurt himself on the blue fires, blue fires
or you have a chance to drop, okay this is what we don't want with him spawning loads of different
little guys, because that is gonna add up to damage over time which we're not interested in,
you might notice our little buddy is bringing in some big massive hand, that is called big brother
or little brother, his hand comes up, right here we go, so key piece two, getting both parts opens
a big golden door, don't worry about the golden door okay, I doubt we're gonna do it, 25% angel
room chance and our chance for an eternal heart goes up just a smidge, an eternal heart if you
take it to the next floor will give you a full red heart, but again our angel deal chance has now
just gone up considerably, now we are full health so we don't need to bomb this fire for a chance of
soul heart, we are good to go, so that was an incredibly good one, no we're not going down the
alt path, I'm too scared and it's too late anyway, we're not going against mother, we're going against
mum, we have discovered both of our lovely jubbly secret rooms, we do have 15 bucks which is not
enough for the red key, although I'll be honest and say I have zero success finding the ultra
secret room, I see that I am description mode, oh yes, the creator Ed McMuffin as he likes to go
by, whoa we got a library, oh we have no keys, oh that's not good, okay libraries if there's three
books inside gives a, whoa a transformation chance to get bookworm which means we will have a chance
to throw out two tiers pair, like two tiers like this, we need, whoa, I am so bad at dodging
anything, did you see those spiders come, oh sorry fuck them up Gamma, Gamma, Gamma, Gamma go, right
we do have a key, I'm gonna risk it and hopefully we get rewarded with bookworm with three books inside
close enough, right 40 damage to all in the room or a black heart however
using the item before boss fight makes the reward a devil deal, purchasing it does cost
does not affect item pedestals in the voice, now I am going to take this, the reason is because
it is infinite health source, I, I have faith, unfortunately this key beggar, I'm sorry I have
no keys, he will have a higher chance to drop a key which he does, thank you very much, we say
thank you pickaxe for doing your duties, you've done us fantastic, we have discovered all the secret
rooms so far, we are going to ultimate because we can basically take devil items and be rewarded
without the penalty of not being a loud angel, I am absolutely messing this up, sorry the,
the familiars hook attack is really messing up with my eyes right now, yeah that's right just
blame the game, blaming the game on itself, yeah maybe I'm just a bad player, I don't know you'll
never know, devil items statistically are very strong however angel items you can roll an
absolute terrible angel room, you can absolutely terrible like I don't know I guess the urn thing
that pot thing that I never bother with is just awful, a little mushroom guys they have a lot of
HP, I don't know if I want to use a key on that, I'll use a key, two bombs in exchange of one key
when our economy on bombs is pretty high is perfectly fine, it's a bit rough but it's fine,
we could go for this, ah fuck it, let's just go for the chest, let's see what's inside,
let's see what's inside, oh we, oh we have an extra soul heart, fuck it,
okay guess I deserve that, you suck, okay, yeah soul heart, rubbish that's why I hardly ever do
the curse room because it's so stinky honestly, okay that was really lucky that our guy has curved
bullets, now because we have so much HP we could consider the sacrifice room rather dangerous but
but I mean we're not doing, we're not doing bad, these guys aren't too rubbish, a little bit rubbish,
they kind of suck, we could consider it because actually I'm feeling risky you know that I'm
feeling riskier, I'm feeling a bit riskier, is this where the secret room is, yes, player instinct,
so this is a mimic chest, do you notice the blood on the bottom right, this, you will have to sacrifice
health in order to access this chest, now I am going to do it because we have the wafer,
whoop, whoop, we got a bomb and some money again, not, not absolutely not, the chest
cannot hurt you, once you've opened up the mimic chest cannot hurt you, so don't worry,
the sac room will give us a lot of piggy bank money, you are absolutely correct little rifling,
thank you for reminding me, I think we're gonna do it, I think we're gonna be a bit crazy
into the sacrifice room, now I will talk through the sacrifice room and I will give you all the
secret deets and all, but the reason we're gonna do it is because it's going to significantly
raise our, or it should anyway, significantly raise our angel chance which means we don't have to skip
a floor of no chance, it's very good to try and avoid having no kind of reward, now you'll always
have a boss item, you'll always have a treasure room, don't get me wrong, again we have the bible,
right, there should be a pay to win machine in here, ah, oh no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
have satanic bible, right, those flies can't hurt you but they can take away charges on your active
item, so for example satanic bible has six active charges, those little guys will come and bop you
and all you'll hear is mew, mew, we are not gonna spend our money just yet because I want to see
what the shop has to offer but we might purposely roll for conjoined, let's see what the shop has
to say first before we make a decision, okay, now we are just gonna kind of run around, we are
getting poison damage by our familiar, very happy with that, again free, there, no, okay unfortunately
it's a, no, okay, the more money you hold in your hand the more likely you are to spawn a greed
fight, this is called a greed fight, there are no items in the shop, we are very lucky to have the
membership passive which means we do still have access to a shop down below, it's not restockable,
I'm like 99% sure it's not restockable the way we, this shop would be, oh no, gammy,
you're too late, I messed up, I lost some hearts for that, I suck, gammy, I've let you down but
thank you for your service, gamgoo, we appreciate you, okay, let's see what we're looking at,
we've got a necronomic, we can sacrifice, 50% chance for a treasure room, I think we're on floor
three so there's like three more, no, no, we're better with restock, we have very good economy,
look at A.C. just hiding behind the ladders, A.C. do you want to, oh well there you go, we are
going to do the sacrifice room now because again we have the wafer which makes sacrifice rooms
very worth its while and I'm feeling lucky, okay so because I have the item description it tells
me exactly what's coming up next, 50% chance for a coin, do you feel, are you feeling lucky
brief ones, are you, oh yeah right because we have piggy bank we got more, okay we didn't
actually get a payout so look 67% chance for an increase, we didn't get it, of course we didn't,
okay we've got a chest, let's go, bomb and a key, lovely, lovely, okay are, wow it only did 6% are you
serious, okay okay yeah one more, right we got our heart back that's fine so this one
you bop it, run out, run away, run inside, spawn the angel and go bombs, go fuck them up,
fuck them up, go gammy, go gammy, go, right the reason why we're destroying this angel,
yes I know there's a host in the corner I'm trying to avoid him, the reason we do this is
because we now have two key pieces, look our angel it has increased again I shouldn't have picked
that up yet, okay this is the last upgrade, it's 50-50, money or soul hearts, okay this is very good
for us we're gonna keep the restock box, trinket, it means there'll be a restock machine that spawns
in our lovely jubbly treasure room, item room and we are gonna focus on that, I am now going to use
satanic bible because we're going to try and maximize our hearts now that we've done that so
we're just gonna roll, I see you're right on top of the item so it's a bit hard to tell what we're
looking at, no not very good, unfortunately we actually have too many soul hearts etc
and we don't need to spawn Gabriel because we have a full key piece already so there's no need to
spawn Gabriel, no need at all we've got full key it will not increase our angel chance or anything
like that don't worry and so again candy to heart we can't even utilize well we have far too much
soul and black hearts or neck hearts, it's not a bad item but it's not what I'm looking for I
really prefer conjoined right now, I mean I mean it's all right it's not terrible but it's not
quite what we're looking for, the d20, if only we were in greed mode I
I don't care that was very unfortunate that we didn't get a conjoined for that
and we cannot enter the battle dome because we're not 1 hp sometimes it will open up under
other circumstances but that was very unlucky and that we didn't really get I should have taken that
and was it not the cloak wheel now we have such high economy it's definitely worth it to go to
this judgment he's not a beggar he's a judgment right so bombs are a two tile radius so one tile
two tiles does that make sense there we go and then we're just gonna jam ourselves in the corner
and then this judge
two coin judgment streamer luck two coin judgment is insane
two coin judgment gash galley okay I don't like him because he sprints halfway across the map
that is insane streamer luck two coin judgment judgment normally asks for a pretty penny off of
you I'm talking around um at least 15 like almost an exchange rate at the shop truly
um that was insane we're just gonna check I think the secret room might be somewhere in here
unfortunately I am very bad at finding obscure secret rooms yeah um we'll just press onwards
and maybe it's outside the boss room um but a cheap day on oh well okay whoa that's so good
as well come here please thank you now um do you notice how the water almost looks like an arrow
pointed to here you know what I'm not gonna speak again for the evening um thank you for listening
to me it's been fantastic uh I was going to say the game likes to hint where the secret room is to
you normally it can be there so yeah unfortunately our super secret room is elsewhere please I am
embarrassed do not acknowledge that now we're gonna keep the joker card on us in case of failure
because this will take us to the angel no matter what okay we've got bumbo the poor lad just wants
a bit of cash honestly um bumbo has a secret ah gammie please I'm doing so terrible please gammie
um bumbo has a secret if he picks up I think seven to nine coins he will actually spot I am
just not dodging anything at all thank goodness we have the wafer so we did fail but we have conjoined
so conjoined means our damage goes down but what do you notice
shot superiority gained oh yeah baby now we're gonna use the joker card to get us to our angel deal
and it's absolute caca thanks for the waste of time mate uh see this is the problem that I have
with Isaac you have angel and devil deals that don't give you anything so this is an example of
you should have gone the devil and you shouldn't have wasted your joker card but we're gonna go back
and pick up our little black room here because it's very op thank you thank you oh wait I am going
to use the black room on the d20 and we will hopefully get some sort of stat upgrade that is
useful and not to range because we already have 10 range is that tears right okay we got tears right
up I'll take it tears right up we have quite efficient now I cannot guess where the secret room
is I already popped the bomb there I'm sorry I'm just looking at the map for a possibility but
unfortunately these kind of the bigger the map gets the weaker my guesses are did we do this
am I being done I've already done the shop look I'm in no rush before and it's like
eh you're taking so long to play the game relax chase chase we're just trying to enjoy ourselves
I think it's right above you possibly all right we're gonna buy this car because we might as well
right we've got the full card I'm gonna keep um I never played this game but I'm impressed with
the amount of detail oh it's a very good game I thought here right we've only got three bombs so
this is it one or done nah all right we're out we're already we're out of 5000 um but yes we
if we pick up one more book we also get bookworm which means we'll spam even more shots
for the price of no passive really um but we're just gonna go next I don't see any tinted rock in
this room sometimes a boss fight has I don't know if it has a higher chance of a tinted rock
but I seem to personally have a bias eh straight up fire rate yes sorry did I say the wrong thing
fire rate yeah my tears come out faster so this is a different kind of battle dome room
um we could full card it if we want however if we do this we get more uh active item
entering a new floor that's it's not bad but because we have such high economy
eh see we've just charged our active bar there and these enemies aren't oh my gosh why do I have
such terrible damage I know I just took conjure at conjure conjoined as well which doesn't make
this any easier oh I freaking hate these guys so much you can only hit them on the back of their head
gammy why don't you come out like when I'm not perishing how about you come out like
right now gammy and just deal with them please I'm so bad you can get I can't remember what the
trinkets called it gives you a one in five chance of spawning a bird pair kill in the room uh I
absolutely adore it whoa that was good that shatter right we're doing it we're doing it so for this
room that's a yuck heart we actually don't want that it's worth not a full heart if that makes sense
it's worth half a heart it does let you have a blue fly though that goes after enemies but it's not for
me that's this niche for my um so that those two fires might indicate the secret room is also there
the game likes to do double fires a lot can you stop pooping please um the game loves to do
double fires like absolutely adores it I can't stop it normally again it's another indication
that the secret room might be there no I don't I don't know if we're doing the curse oh okay so that
was another hint no it wasn't I just suck at this game you know what you know what game you embarrass
me anymore I'm taking it up with a pope or something are you drunk right we're not going in those rooms
anymore we're actually not going in the cursed room anymore we've had absolutely nothing from it
I've been they're making a mockery out of me they're making a mockery out of me right sorry any pop
satanic bible um so we actually now have no angel deal chance what the heck am I mistaken
because I pulled a joker card wait if I completely messed up this run I mean honestly we can go to
the devil because of how much HP and the wafer in combination so honestly I'm not that mad I'm not mad
I promise I'm not mad bro I'm not absolutely raging at the fact that uh we've just lost angel deals
for some reason it must have been because I pulled the joker card um but this is the game that I
learned tarot cards in I know we've been playing balutro recently or balutro as I call it um
normally the wee secret room does spawn in this room in between these guys but I wasn't paying
attention to where they spawned the enemies will also give you a hint if they're here but fuck it we'll
try it I give it wait satanic bible raise took away my angel deal
it's not fair give it back oh I hate these guys oh my god they like extend their neck
if you get too close to you oh come on give me come on give me bend and spoon come on give me bend
yeah boss oh for goodness sake right okay well I've kind of gone on a bit of a side quest
that was useless poster oh my god please I'm not even hitting anything these guys in the middle
are just getting a free wall upon me honestly right again we're now full health actually thanks to
the satanic bible right there we go boom and we got a key which is good uh unfortunately yeah as
the game gets larger and larger map wise I find it much so harder to find the secret rooms unless
we can get blue treasure map in the shop potentially potentially blue treasure map allows you to see
the secret and super secret room it does not reveal the ultra secret room but again we need red
key to access that which we did pass on and I'm not familiar if there's any I see please um
they're not too wow we've completely changed we don't have so many keys but hardly any bombs
whoa scary guy we're just gonna spray them down in the middle
how weak how weak is our attack holy crap we need like a damage anything please again we have
another heart this is a unique room I don't recall ever being in it you can play this game for hours
upon hours and enter a room layout you've never seen before in your life super secret rooms are
usually close to the boss and connected to only one room okay they're not like this room
okay okay uh-huh oh yeah uh-huh whoa it dropped a uh chest uh are these called globes or something
whoa we have a guppy it's very unlikely we're gonna get guppy
I don't hate infestation
I feel like we can get something better though
I hate it wait no I hate it stop giving me active I um
huh right
the reason I'm taking this is because it can phd it turns all bad pills to good
and it can put your stats up I get yet instantly we've been gratified by our choice our speed is
now up we can also take pills which is fantastic um I ran away from this pill what we got 48 hour
energy which is not quite what we're looking for but that's okay but like again if there's
no pills in the shop we can utilize
okay so okay right get them gammy get them gammy that's right so if you're incredibly unlucky
and you have a lot of money on hand your chance of getting super greeds goes up it's exponentially
and we have been very unlucky to now miss out on two freaking shops but we did get an item pedestal
I'm not gonna pick it up just yet in case there's some trickery you picked it up and dropped it again
did I actually oh my god what are you lunch no what are you the livers what are you
yera which duplicates whatever goodness I mean
that's terrible yeah I have to admit this is probably the most frustrating mechanic
I am playing normal mode the odds of us getting greed actually shouldn't be that high but
if you play hardcore mode for unlocks you without fail yera
I'm gonna hold on to yera yera duplicates so if we find something like a a pill maybe the um
does is good so we are full money there's a room I didn't explore off to the side here my bed oh well
I shouldn't have discovered it I take it all back but anyway we can take pills now and when we do
blood donation machines we get even more money for it unfortunately we are having just terrible
luck trying to get what we need um we don't need any of that the lean bags secret room is left of
the treasure room do you solemnly swear wifling that is your final decision left of the treasure room
okay if this if this secret room is not here you're being timed out
whoa the bomb follow does ah we just wasted a bomb doing that
no one move it okay you're not being timed out congrats unfortunately we are full
we are very full of coins and we have nowhere to spend it and we destroyed the donation machine
and we don't have an arcade machine uh arcade level I think arcade spawns every odd even four
if you have five coins or more something like that um
unfortunately we don't have enough bombs to try and find the super secret room
what we got looky a bit of looky oh yeah a bit of looky
yeah you like that yeah unfortunately he's a bam and uh yeah I'm gammie you know I meant that
that was actually a tactical move to unlock gammie so gammie does all the work for us it was a
tactical move it was a tactical move stop it stop calling me a new bin Isaac look I play it for fun
okay too many sweats and Isaac too many sweats and Isaac this is what I just played for fun see gammie
does all the work if there is ever a game where it was all about familiars I'll be in the development
team because I like when the familiars do the work and I get to lay back and just enjoy the game
I get to enjoy the music the aesthetics I get to enjoy the game design like come on come on go gammie go
oh we get flay absolutely we are gonna take that and we're gonna pop satanic bible and we're
gonna see what satan has to offer us we might actually get guppy the odds of getting guppy are
like so rare we might actually do it holey moley well now that we have flight we're gonna take a
little uh detour so when you have flight uh floor spikes can't stop you um I'm gonna grab that heart
um but uh obviously you're not limited to the floor um crazy concept of the flight I know um I
know I should probably take up through his head but uh due to the fact that satanic bible will help
me out with health I oh but you have wafer you have wafer I know I know but I suck you can see I
suck and to be honest we're actually not doing I should have taken the full card not that we're
gonna be able so are you gonna point and do in this room because yeah I was gonna say if it's money
then what's the point all right let's go oh flight is just so easy oh wait no there's gonna be a
full card in this floor anyway um if I wanted to use it but it's not like we can get boss rush
it's been an hour and we've not even perished mother dearest the most basic mother dearest
mom's heart is it mom's heart no mom's heart it's the next one it's just man
oh I should stop picking up coins oh the spider's coming at you no I'm hiding get away from me
go away I'll let go away I'll let my familiars deal with you go away no I'm not taking any
damage because you guys are ganging up on me so you notice that um black one over there how his
pathing's given up because he's like I can't reach you it's actually quite humorous to do that in
the game I like it um the game's just like I cannot reach you I give up um the game also has a soft
lock feature um if you're in a room for too long uh the game will actually unlock it itself because
it's like hold on a minute something isn't right you should be out of this room by now basically
uh a treasure room for free sure sure okay mother's bra no we'll pass but thank you for
the kind offer though uh an orbital no we don't really let enemies get that close to us a coin no
no not on health either oh we're gonna say we no that's an act
poggers poggers wait triple oh wait we okay we're gonna we're going up in damage but hold on let me
cook hold on hold on let's see the damage let's see what happens whoo okay hold on wait I may have
messed up a little bit but it's fine it's fine I actually don't mind this it's cute it's cute look at
it look at it going everywhere we're just oh a Christmas miracle and we get f all of course we
get f all right hopefully there's an item down here won the run with that literally now we could get
midnight snack I don't want too many red hearts oh wait no the devil's gonna ask for that um
automatically charges the first bar yeah if we could get that in greed mode that in the sprinkler
that'd be great yeah that's all I need okay unfortunately the last shops have been yeah this
is the last shop it's been uh rather disappointing I'll just buy stuff because I can really um
justice uh justice yeah this is where I learned my tarot cards from justice gives you one of each
pick up basically uh it does have a chance to give you a troll bomb that's on the town side
um we are gonna just quickly kablamo these guys um have I used the bible this I'm gonna make sure
to get an extra devil item because we are we're starting to not be now we do have flight the
mobility that you get from flight is very important for like dodging enemies like for example this enemy
I can I call me Duke can you come because I'm juking his ankles or something I don't know um
maybe the secret room above here nope it's not uh that was why it's good to check rooms
but like see how we're doing so much damage from across the room it's kind of splitting
chat it's splitting um like oh fantastic again because of flight we don't have to spend a bomb
and we can just see what's in this rubbish rubbish don't waste our time so again we can
kind of hide behind items as well that obscure the enemy shots of us um the let's say the secret
room might be here nope okay I will never speak again it looks like the secret room might be
somewhere I don't know well we can pick this up now that's the name I haven't heard in a while
what Duke you come that's a lot of words too bad I ain't reading them um
no not here what the heck not there either
the only problem with conjoined uh was it hetero chromium or whatever I've forgotten the name
of the the shooty one um it gets very chaotic on the screen very messy on the screen I mean it could
be to the left here one of our secret rooms I don't want to take any damage for this room though
um and also notice how our tears we're kind of having to like guess okay thank goodness
whoa no no no oh okay if this guy gets bombed he does not perish bomb beggar does not perish to
bombs if you enrage him basically now I'm not gonna it's a shame he's not a general uh
judgment or a bit oh well I don't know we might get we might get a rock out of this
we did we got a small rock okay thankfully damage up again sorry my voice just cracked out of
excitement uh we got damage up again oh holly molly sorry uh clearly uh playing uh fixed game if you
wanted to play the uh seed with me it's tka1gv1y um if you want to play the seed don't you don't
have to where the heck is the boss room oh I've walked past it sorry sorry I literally I was like
there's a chance it could be small rock in here now notice this room and now if we don't kill her
notice how you see mom's eyes coming through the door holes etc um and she's going Isaac Isaac
okay keep that in mind keep in mind before I say what I'm gonna say next after the fight
oh I didn't even know you were in here sorry oh we failed the devil deal which is a shame
right did you notice how she was looking through the door almost as if she was peeping inside the
chest and she finds Isaac and she's trying to desperately get inside we're still on time for
boss rush one you're hilarious two oh my gosh I took me an hour to get to the mum fight the most
basic level six mum fight um but yes uh when I talk about my uh when I do the review on this game
which I'm very excited to do um I'm gonna talk about all my little theories because everyone's
like got different theories about it but mine's like the reason why everything's rectangular is
because it's you in the chest but um you heard your mum go Isaac we are gonna go down and we're
picking up even more damage um the satanic bible doesn't work on that floor but that's fine
no boss rush but maybe hush are you joking me you guys are having a Fibonacci sequence on me because
you're you're having me on what was that range okay okay right I'm just gonna pop satanic bible
now it doesn't really matter if we take damage because um range you'll notice the tears aren't
actually hitting we're just having to guess the path of the tears it's not when you have this
I've completely forgotten the name of that item when you have it you're not really actually aiming
to hit directly with the tear you're even in front of them now our luck is gone up which means our
drop rate on items uh is gone up which is nice and cool do appreciate um but we're just gonna
walk around have a little uh have a peek into all the rooms we're not really we are not in
trouble let's just say we're not in trouble I feel confident about this run I was a bit nervous
uh he hemo claria hold on hold on hold on wait hold on need to stop swallowing what are you
swallowing stop it someone is swallowing a hemo lacrea okay that's it hemo lacrea yeah you have
to aim a bit funny we're hemo lacrea sorry let's do me a hold second now because what right if this
isn't a guppy item you're not forgiving game close enough close enough uh what are you spawns a devil
are you joking come on that's rubbish right we're gonna do it
I was a terrible idea
come on chaos card I mean I'll take it oh he gave us two hearts what the heck sure
and what tablet have you given us luck up
tears and damage and two black hearts and leviathan transformation right we're gonna pick this up
hold on wait I'm gonna drop it real quick so I can read out what it does we've just picked up the
chaos card using the card throws it in the direction Isaac is moving instantly kill any
enemy except delirium and beasts so we can pretty much just instantly do this fight if we so desire
um it's very good I'm gonna pick up the red hearts but we're not gonna go all the way back
and we we got the pact which is fantastic absolutely fantastic is this a chance for the
hidden room hey let's go whoa we got binge here temporarily two permanent startups depending
on the food this is streamer luck because what on earth
seriously binge eaters sitting in the secret room what is this luck
well there's like an extra eye in here stop it
literally 13 damage right now uh I'm tempted to do mega satan just for the hell of it
we'll do the lamb and then we'll turn back for mega satan are you coming what are you doing
okay okay we've got him we've got bomba
I envy you give me your luck honestly this is like the best you didn't run I think I've ever had
uh we do have a reroll if we wanted to redo this floor no rerolls all of Isaac's items no sorry
this run is far too good to be mucking about with that if the run was bad and we were like struggling
then yeah but no we're good okay luck our luck is now three after literally one floor it was
like terrible no not gambas no this is you don't understand how good this run is like how good
we've got it we've got infinite health we've got um opens all secret rooms okay we don't even have to
think now there we go there we've got one secret room just like that
oh we got pill room let's go opens all secrets up all secrets are you joking
are those three those are three I can see forever's wow that was
I know I've got the chaos card but hear me out I'd rather actually be able to see the next
secret rooms as well on the next floor and be like I know it's a chaos card you can instantly kill
wait we can instantly kill mega satan with that hold on hold on I'm being dumb we'll we'll do mega
satan okay we'll do mega satan we'll do lamb and then we'll do mega satan and then we'll see if
we can get a delirium portal and and send it in delirium all right we've already done the other
secret room uh right okay okay okay we might be able to get the portal might I don't know
but we're just gonna spam away we're gonna mind our own business over here keep spamming away
uh blast assist splits into we are the ones um which is pretty nice
um there's a lot of theme really re-apparent themes with the enemies
I don't want false phd that's rubbish um a light snack um we'll take and again another example of a
freaking devil deal not being a thing yeah and of course there's no guffy that would be too easy
luck up sure tears up I'll actually take and range sure why not that was rubbish
don't speak to me or my children ever again
and real what about brimstone honestly curse of the blind how dare you
okay we're gonna do him again because he was really good to us
uh don't be shy now
what what's this one sure don't be shy now
for goodness sake I can't believe we're doing this but
we're gonna sacrifice the health we're gonna drop the chaos card here
go back inside and we're gonna turn everything into a fucking heart there jeez you're so needy
mister beggar honestly you better give me something good that's all I'm saying hold
holy moly please mister what is it damage up and fear shot okay so enemies are gonna back up off us
which is uh range up as well sure sure enemies are gonna back up off our yaks
um it's not really much point in this trinket anymore but we'll just carry it as a as a thank you
to pay homage to it giving us absolutely nothing if i'm not mistaken and we actually
didn't get anything from it um more damage good very good oh I didn't actually see that
shot coming that was on me you know what else last night your mom thank you I'm sorry I'm sorry
I just right it might be here the secret room no no get him I know I just completely gave up
I was like trying to see it but I'm like no I just gave up whoa really too okay thank goodness
we're all p because this room can be very dangerous but you should drop the monkey paw
yeah I personally oh we're one away for guppy though
right we're one away from guppy that we could get guppy from a chest
we could get guppy from a chest I'm picking it up close enough close enough we can come back
maybe there might be a sacrifice room yep well you're not guppy um right okay guppy
guppy nope that's not guppy okay one more time guppy's tail guppy's tail
I have bingier I have bingier that could have been that I have bingier
are you kidding me okay okay right tick talk tick
I could have been guppy twice
that could have been guppy twice oh because we're on freaking curse of the blind are you kidding me
um brah one oh for goodness sake I was gonna start counting there we maxed tears we are maxed
tears brah we could add guppy that's fine
wow okay let's see what's in the chest give us guppy guppy's tail give us guppy's tail
wait no I just need the keys not the money I'm still money guppy's tail guppy's tail guppy's tail
guppy is the name of my dead cat and Isaac's I'm Isaac oh wait sorry wait this guy doesn't want you
should um right guppy's can I please please stop shouldn't thank you
I don't need any of this oh increase your devil deal chance by doing that
I would like it I don't know if we're gonna get it but I would like it but are we gonna get
guppy's tail guppy's tail sure give us that I can see forever
oh oh oh what's going on here oh making me nervous guppy's tail guppy's tail
come on I waited I like hesitated when I opened it
guppy has a tail no no cursed are you serious
are you serious cursed I
I
cursed freaking I I love all those freaking boxes we could have had guppy I get cursed I
okay cursed I gives us five shots but you have to freaking charge it up
oh for god's sake we're gonna get bingey or again by accident
for god no yes okay we got something oh I should have held on to that oh no I shouldn't have
forget sake yeah no okay we got incubus I'll take it
okay incubus wait incubus does what I do hold holy moly incubus does what I do okay you everything
cursed I cursed freaking I yeah yeah right what are you empty heart empty heart container
I mean mezzo just take breakfast I don't want to get too many red hearts though that's my problem
oh we can do the boss fight if we want though I need to pull satanic bible
okay maybe maybe cursed I wasn't actually too bad holy moly this is insolent right at least I can see
no that's actually we're kind of wrecking in deck and like I don't want to say it but maybe it
wasn't the worst thing that could happen bro they can't even get close to us right we're gonna pop satanic
bible to get an item I do want to reduce my red health because it's getting very big and I actually
do last chance for guppy right now
how are you we're doing good we're getting trolled a little bit but we definitely have
streamer luck on our side but we're trying to get gupsters and it's just no quite happening
the way we want it to which is fine wow we went completely guppy give us guppy guppy guppy guppy
not sure what happened but this is gonna go well until the moment it suddenly doesn't oh no we can't
lose I am I we literally cannot lose at this point in time we have the wafer we have so much
going for us like that attack is just that shit insane it is why am I should I just go for the
boss fight I don't really think we need to explore the room secret room looks like it's gonna be here
actually I really need to stop doing that nope okay I tell the lie right we'll pop the bible so we
can get a cheeky bit of it I forgot I forgot I forgot why I didn't realize we were already here
ah come on Gabby oh wow he's not even doing a freaking lick of damage hold on
wait
wait cursed I is in teleport every time I take damage no I thought it was oh my god
oh my god I have to follow only if you're charging up
tap shoot what do you mean tap shoot I don't have a tap shoot
oh
so
oh hold on
hold on
hold on okay hold on hold on hold on hold on locking in locking in locking in locking in locking in
We are going to purposely burn our neck crows. We're gonna purposely burn them
And gammy's out I repeat gammy is out gammy is on the case gammy is on the case
We are not helpless only a little bit gammy's gonna do it come on buddy
Definitely could use BFF unfortunately
We're gonna keep we're just gonna have to do it this way. I do not want teleported out
Come on gamgoo you can do it, buddy. I believe you
Get one more
Come on, come on
Okay, okay, come on gammy gammy. It's up to you now. I'm on red heart damage
Gammy gammy hit gammy
Focus gammy. Okay, there we go
Wow, we are not doing mega Satan to known surprise
I'm gonna go pick up the hearts. I completely forgot it did that. I
Knew it was bad
But I completely forgot I did that
To say I'm upset as a wee bit of an understatement
Okay, maybe we are in trouble no mega Satan oh we do have the chaos card for me no cuz mega has two phases
so we can't
Make it has two feet. I think we're gonna have to use it on the lamp. I don't I don't think we're getting out here alive
Right, I will drop the monkey paw
Pick up the chaos card though
Oh, we have gupsters. Okay, we have guppy here bowl
I
Percent chance for a rift. I'll take that and then we'll do health here
Were you a backstabber hitting an enemy in the back? Yeah?
Oh
Okay, I need to I need to enter the room boss charged
Okay, yeah me you do the rest
Even though even though I didn't take damage get me you do the rest this is
Democracy manifest
Okay, okay, okay, that was lucky. Okay, that's a mimic chest and we're not interested
Notice all the flies that's because we have guppies transformation. Wow that actually saved us I
Worried
We just need we just gonna take the snack
We got guppy up by what cost honestly honestly though
How could I be so foolish
I'm gonna take the foot taking a damage
chance
I might actually take that on the basis of if gammy gets summoned out and he's our last lifeline
Are she sorry
Grants a random zodiac. Fuck it. What is it? What we getting? I
Don't know what zodiac we got there
Oh, yeah, I'm always pop the babel. Sorry
We are sorry, I am having a try hard so much right now
Right, what's that double shot wait, did that remove course I know
Just make things worse for myself I it's very possible
Don't charge don't charge go little flies go go guppy flies go. Oh that this orbital actually take the heat off of us
I'm an idiot. It's not the one. I thought it was it was a freaking fly. I thought it was the fly that goes around the wall
I am a dumb dumb
Tears shoot slowing effect. I mean no, it's too late for any of these transformations
It's too late guppy can carry you through the lamp save chaos for mega. Yeah, I
Will try mega if we lose we lose at least we like literally had to which one though
Contact them makes Isaac Isaac immune to damage and deals
Nah, that's rubbish
So I owe you. Well, thank goodness. There wasn't an enemy in there. I wasn't charged up
Okay, and we're gonna go do the lamb. I have no idea. Oh, I keep forgetting
Okay, oh
I'll take it. I'll take it. We're where was it? Oh, it's below a
Fart bean a little fart bean. Okay, we'll do a health. No, actually
We'll do the fart bean because it's funny and I like it, okay
If I just do that, it's just gonna okay. Okay. I see you see I don't really want to take
Right, we're gonna do it. We're gonna do lamb and then we're gonna go back to mega Satan
No damage no damage, okay, the rift is helping us out insanely right now because it's sucking him
Okay, we're gonna go do mega Satan
We're actually gonna go do mega Satan with freaking cursed I I am going to go into the other rooms
I didn't realize how much of a speed down we had. Wow. How did I only just notice that?
We're gonna hopefully get something
Sure, why not? Let's get you root emick to you. I really can't take much more health. We are so slow. Oh
Wait, there's a there is a a pill in here. Is it a speed pill? That would be great. Not gonna lie
What are you?
No, I
Do we can someone look up do we need face to Satan with chaos card mega Satan face to magazine
Oh, does more health slow you down? Yes, we have what's called binge eater and and every time we pick up a health
We do get damage, etc. Sadly though
Yeah, I can't see all right, sorry, I can't see what's going for me. That scared me
I
Probably better to kill
Phase one with chaos at least yes two phases. Okay, what and then just don't mess up five heads
Just don't mess up chaos car chaos card only kills one phase. I thought that
Thought that
Yes to be probably better to kill phase one because it's the longest phase okay
Can we do it?
No pressure. I
Mean the good news is you can try phase one a billion times each failure only costs half of her
Take the bad chest and use the book
I
Don't it's not gonna have an item only. Oh, it does have an item in it another charged attack. I'll pass right fuck it
We'll take this
No, let's go
Your flies will melt through phase one if you get hit on phase two you'll tell you
Let's try it come on what you got your fucking bam come on
Come on
Okay, we've got rift which will suck a lot of attack away, but we must be careful
We must be careful
We must be careful. I'm sweating. I'm sweating. Oh my god
We have we have no way we have the zodiac over out. We're out take your time
That was so dangerous, I'm not laughing
Oh, it hit me cuz I touched it. I didn't see what touched me
I don't know
Did Satan touch my butthole? I didn't
Come on mega Satan we can do it
Come on come on
Okay, he's gonna be scared. He's gonna be telling his parents about how terrified he is of a little five-year-old boy. Come on
Come on baby come on baby
No, no, no, no, no not charging not charging not charging charging charging charging
Enemy acquired
Whoa
Whoa suck them up suck them up. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa. Whoa
Oh
Of course it's fricking envy nothing to envy bro, that's a really good book on South Korea. Hey, North Korea my apologies
Whoa
Hold on hold on the four the four four four great
Come on. Rift is coming in clutch
I'm so slow. I'm so slow
Oh
Okay, we're on the angels one shot in the angels come on gammie come on gammie
We're not in phase two yet, it's okay
I'm gonna do this and the rift is gonna take the heat. I repeat the rift is going to take the heat
Come on face to face to come on point the card point the card point the card point the card
Don't mess up point the card point the card pointing pointing card through
Where the fuck is the card?
Hello
Where did the card go? How is it there? I?
Wasn't on that side of the map
How is it there? How is it there? I wasn't on that side of the map. I
Wasn't even there am I going crazy help help help actually have to do the Satan fight with cursae I
Wasn't on that side of the map though
Please guppy's flies do it please
Please
Please guppy, please
I got me baby boy. Come on guppy. Oh
We did it delirium
Delirium no, but we did it
The rift sucked my card. Oh
We did it yatta. Oh
For goodness gravy
Goodness gravy cursed I an exchange of guppy
Oh
Through Isaac he sees himself as a bad boy, but he's not a bad boy. We did it first try that was crazy
I kept my card got sucked out of my hand
It literally was like when something gets blown in the wind that you're hold on holding I
Can't believe we did that. I was ready to go to delirium for the hell of it. Oh
This is such a creepy credit
Oh
It's such a creepy credit, but oh my god, how did we do that?
Flex missed the chaos card to prove that you didn't need it
Honestly that run could not have gone any better Satanic Bible. I have to admit is fantastic
You get unlimited health from it statistically when you find energies around the map you get unlimited health
You get extra devil deal items on top of what you're doing. Anyway, I'm
Satan and shambles literally Ed McMillan. I hope it's the next time
And Ed McMuffin is currently working on a game called me eugenics
Which I'm very excited for its release. Sadly. There was a bit of delay in development
And due to a few issues and him adding on extra things and I will say that I've played Isaac
I definitely feel and I have got my money's worth and
From it yellow baby, wait, I'm not I actually unlocked something there
Wait, did I not do mega Satan on?
Who was it who's a plane on Eden? I didn't do mega. Wait, where the fuck is Eden Eden? There you are. Oh
Wow, I never actually had the thing
Is it over? Um, no, we're gonna do one very cheeky
greed mode with
Lilith and then yeah, we did it. We won though
I've faith Isaac and super meat boy. We're both incredible. Yes, I believe you unlocked a court, baby
Yeah, I can't believe we did that right. We're gonna do a little greed mode. I'm just gonna show you greed mode
It's super simple to get the grass Bob. A lot of people don't seem to enjoy it. I for one enjoy it
So I've got my little sookie bus, but look I have no eyeballs, so I can't cry if you didn't em know
The attack in these games are about crying because poor Isaac is crying himself. Um, so this is a room
It is a rectangular long rectangle. Um, they are going to be 10 phases
You might notice that there that little 10 there that is saying what phase we're on
There will be 10 fights in this room back to back to back to back
There is a timer to tell you in the next comment. There's a locked door. There's an open room
And we're going to get a range upgrade and a heart. We're going to hope
Unfortunately, we did not get a soul or a necro heart. That's okay. 169 tokens exactly
Now curious deep pockets, we're not probably gonna get anything like that. Oh anonymous
Thank you so much for the tip. I'm glad you
Enjoyed my victory royale literally flexing on them
So in greed mode your only
Opportunity to make money is via fights and that is the only way you can upgrade your stuff. Okay
so
Um, but there's a few hidden a few hidden differences. Okay a few hidden differences
um, we can
Bomb these
Keepers here. These are passed away keepers
Um, and we actually have a higher chance of getting things like keepers head for example or steam sail for example
They have a high chance of dropping a cheeky quarter
No, not quarter five cents
um
But yes, so we want to try and get a key which is five bucks to get into our room now
Because we are lileth. We don't really want an active item at all. We like
Look now we have two we have double the firepower because of that move
So, uh, this can get out of hand very quickly. Thankfully lileth is the easiest to play
In greed mode. I just kind of want to show you off. But as you see there's a timer
um
Those we enemies are doing their thing again. We are getting a active every time new enemies come in
We're getting an active so now we have three firing power
Um, we definitely want to clear enemies as fast as they come in because once you do not want overwhelmed on the map
As soon as you get overwhelmed that's when your health takes a tank and it is very hard to try and
Like it's expensive to try and roll for a soul heart for example
Again, we now have four firing power. Please don't touch me. Please. Oh really don't want that really don't want that
um
Really don't want that but hey, oh it happened. We're gonna stay in we're gonna do what's called the boss fight
Um, that was very unlucky though very unlucky. Um
So these flies can shoot out. Sorry my fingers getting sore
I actually should take a picture of my controller to show you how intensely I play Isaac
So we have now completed
Um phase eight. So there's like an optional kind of you know boss fight if you will
Now the game. Oh, I shouldn't have popped that actually. That was very silly
Because we needed it for the next floor, but that's on me making mistakes and it's okay. You're allowed to make mistakes in the game
What is the enemy
Oh, it's you guys you stinkers
But yes, um, as you can see why it's easy on Lilith is you just
Continually get more and more damage and as you get any sort of upgrade you get rewarded for it. Okay
So Lilith is all about minions. Yeah, she is my favorite for greed mode because of
The familiar help. I love games that have familiar help. So that purple guy is called lust
I think if i'm remembering correctly, he will try to touch you. You need to try and juke him
Yeah, you need to get rid of him quickly
um
But the good thing with uh, we're actually gonna try and get rid of the baby first because he runs around erratically
Um, which is not good for us. Unfortunately. We have base speed
I can't see the enemy. Okay, we're fine
Now as much as I actually want to go for a devil deal
I'm not interested in greed mode in a devil deal. Okay
So unfortunately, we got absolutely nothing in here which sucks
But hey, so we're gonna get a key
And we're gonna see if we can get a bomb. Unfortunately, we don't have a bomb in this role
So we are gonna get a key and see what's in our active room
Our active room the purple guy
Uh, we've actually got spawns a random pickup. So that's not bad at all
And we're getting a lot of coins from the fires not bad at all indeed
Um, I'm going to avoid the curse room because we do not have the goods now. I could do a tier rates up here
It does seem a shame to miss out on it
But i'm kind of needing a bomb for next round
Oh
Decisions decisions. This is the problem with greed mode
All right. I'm against my my judgment. I'm gonna do this. I'm gonna hope for a bomb
Sadly no bomb
Uh, I'm going to elect to keep my money for the next floor
Um coat hanger pretty good. Yes. So now look how fast it is. Look at him go up here up here up here up here
Yeah
Yes, I always wait for a round with discounted item and try and do that. Yes. That is a very viable tactic
Uh, sure
Sure, why we don't even have eyes
But sure now we can buy a key to instantly get access to that room to see what's going on
Interesting another tears up
Now we're gonna keep
Hold on we're gonna use this key
We're gonna buy two keys
Okay, let me cook. Let me cook
We're gonna unlock one of these to get a bomb because we need it for the angel fight. We're gonna do
Uh, we're gonna bomb him
Wow
Normally they almost always drop something we're gonna see what's in here
I've got Bob's head using the iron and firing it throwing the head explodes where it lands
Uh, we're gonna try and find the the secret. Oh no, I can't be in here. I can't be in here rubbish rubbish
Well, we're just gonna eat it out of the wall. I guess
I
No, there you go
Didn't get it didn't get it. Where'd the angel deal chance go? It only comes up after the boss fight
So we're guaranteed an angel wait. I'm Lilith. Hold on
Hold on a minute. I might not be guaranteed it like a dumbass. I'm Lilith. I'm evil
I may have messed up slightly. I may have done a slight miscalculation
Is it Lilith? Because I know Bethany gives you a higher angel
So I
Unfortunately used up the last
Thing which I shouldn't have done. So we're actually down a little guy. Of course we have hosts
Hosts can easily overrun your game easily. So we really want rid of them like ASAP. That's really bad for
Whoa
You couldn't have done that before we spent our monies
Jeez, we got a golden key. That's such a shame
At least we can get two bombs. Oh my god, our pickup is going wild
Sorry, sorry. I'm getting too distracted
Sorry
What's going on down here?
Definitely don't want them coming near us because we don't want any damage
Oh my god. Oh my gosh. Oh my gosh
That's what I'm saying. You can get overwhelmed just like that. Whoa, wait our bag is multiplying
I just noticed that like an idiot our bag is multiplying. What the heck?
I didn't know the the pickup bag's multiplied. I was like, why are we getting so much good stuff?
Whoa
That's hilarious
That is fun
That oh dear
Oh dear, we're now risky territory because if we go for the next ball. Oh, no. Oh, no
Putta madre. Oh, it's widow
What are you doing? What are you doing? Why are you not coming over? Do you not jump?
Whoa, what's going on?
Creamy little spider you are aren't you?
Spider girl confirmed for gin too
absolutely
No, um
Okay, we are playing it very risky right now, but I do not want to leave the room
So we're gonna we're gonna send it as the as the young one where the heck is the enemy
It's worms. It's wiggly worms and I completely missed all the damage against them
We got bombs though
Okay
We're really playing at risk
We're gonna bomb this angel. I don't think we can actually bomb it
We've not got enough health. We actually can't bomb the angel to increase our angel deal
It's okay
A worm confirmed for gen two actually for real for real though
A little wiggly worm that comes out of the ground and she has an obsession with your prostate
She just wants to poke it. She's like, I just want to poke it
Well, do it no ball. I I certainly do not have any balls. I assure you
I shite bag if you didn't I actually I'm a shite bag
right
Now we have a golden key so we can take these bombs for free
And we got penny back. We need to be very careful in between those spikes
now
Because we have treasure box conjoined is just
insane
The insanity of conjoined goes crazy. So I am going to buy this
Because it gets out of hand so quickly. Oh my god. They look like little diamond
Uh little diamond thingies
um
As much as getting a bone heart would be all right for going in and out the curse room
We actually don't have the money
No, we don't I mean we could
Now they have a higher payout rate
I mean we got five bombs for it. Sheesh
I'll take it. Uh, right as for where this hidden room is it's either in the curse room or it's right here
Yeah, the odds of it being here is pretty high
Decrease spawn rate of all hearts to 20 percent all black all hearts turn into black hearts
Increase the drop chance the keys. I even do anything. I think we'll just do lunch
I doubt I don't think that does anything in greed mode. Uh greed mode does negate a lot of different things. Um
But that's not here not there. Are all the beggars refillings. I'm seeing them really like in mummy
I know they've been so kind in greed mode. The rate goes up exponentially now
This is just a small thing you can do but you can actually bomb these
It will reroll but you can also get money back. So we've actually just been given the chance for damage
And we might spawn a Yara rune
No, this sprinkler this sprinkler is so good
Oh wait, but we're lily so we don't need the sprinkler. It's fine. Right. We have a shard rune
We are going to use it on a gemmed tailstone for the chance to do uh
What the fuck did that do
What did that do? Oh, it made something cheaper in the shop. Oh, I should have saved it for the next floor
I was hoping we were going to get a crawl space and it was going to have an item inside for us, but it's
Okay, right. We have no money, but we have bombs and we have two
Familiar well, we technically only have one for conjoined
It would affect the drops of your mystery bag
Okay, so we now have oh, no
Oh, it hurts
I
Mean dumb dumb
I forgot we had pain
Pain damage multiplier full health pain
Too measly pain
Now we are actually gonna be
It forced a bomb these to try and get a freaking hit
And I bet you if I had money it wouldn't be that
Exactly. Ah, that's right
Unfortunately, we are kind of getting a bit uh needing
A few things now. I'm going to hope my multiplied drops are going to do something
Okay spawns a devil burger. Um
One more for the gentleman in the back
And nothing. Wow, we we're having it rough out here. Let's hope there's something of
Um
We now
Do not have to aim. I repeat for those of you who do not know what homing spoon is. We do not have to aim
Let's
Go
We just need to do a rooty mick tootie in any direction talk about streamer luck
We do not need to aim the game will do it all for us. Oh, I love being a strummer
I just took health damage. Why is there a blinking light bulb? What is that?
What whoa, that's that's a lot of enemies. You're putting my money everywhere
Oh my god, we got a dame as well, which is 10 cents. Are we going eternal heart? Oh, I don't I'm not sure if I want to pick it up yet
Holy moly. Look at all of this goodness
Holy moly
I'm gonna mow this one down because they're not very nice to go against
And then again
Here we go
Whoa, we're getting like special attacks as well now. They do throw bombs. He does throw bombs. So don't don't be too
Okay, one more one more don't take any oh he's it's a poop
He's a wee poopy thing
I don't know what's going on down there. It's chaos, but we're we're spraying and praying boys
Okay, we're spraying and praying. Okay. We've got a devil deal and we have no health to take it
So we are not taking it. We're gonna take the eternal heart, which is fantastic
We're gonna explore and see if there's anything in the room below
Other than enemies got a lot of enemies. So we don't even have to aim
Um, we could bomba like this
Are you joking me?
Are you fucking kidding me? Oh, that one's fucking cute. All right, what's going on in here?
Uh, right, we have a card spawns dev. Well, I can't even utilize your bro
Again, these items are
Rubbage a chest and a chest class the guys like right fuck it
I I want to hold money and okay. Okay. That's better
App absolutely freaking pranked. I like come on
Come on right
Okay, we now have mother transformation. So we now have mom's homing knife. Wait, how does that even work?
It's gonna like home to them when they come to me
Now we are gonna try for secret room here
Didn't get it, but that's okay
Did get three coins now we can go to the angel
I'm just gonna check I picked up the items in the treasure rooms because I forget to do it a lot
It makes the knife powerful. We got mercy. Oh my god mercy for real for real. Okay, we have mercy
Um, did we get a zero? Maybe immaculate conception is a zero technically
Uh, right we go next wait, hold on
We can bomb for a potential discounted item
And get some coins. Oh a money back coins back. Holy crap. I'm so sorry. I stopped talking there and get some coins back
Hold hold it mullet right. We're gonna pick this up because that's damage
Um, oh god, that's damage again
Some what I know I don't know how us if I go into the angel deal it's gonna charge me 30 for something good though
Am I gonna be raging if right? No, I'm gonna be raging if I pass up on something
Oh god, the discount's so good though
Right
Uh range nah, it's fine. Right. We don't need anything. Oh do we need the soul heart?
No, we need 15 bucks for the angel to see what's inside
Wasn't it only 15 it was discounted, but I don't know if it's 30 for the full
Yeah, ah prism actually is fantastic with how much really make tooting and shooting we do
Um
Oh like it's long shield the trinity shield
Oh, no, we just gave her money to the beggar
I
Wasn't paying attention. I was like, oh it's links feel
Uh, I might beat this angel up actually to try and increase my angel
Oh my gosh, did you see that though?
Okay, sorry, I need to try hard. I really don't want to take any damage because we do not have much for
for free
Stop spawning in those guys, please. I can't deal with you all right there
We have no increased angel chance when we do our boss fight
Goodbye bean. We do not need you
And okay damage again
again
seven damage
We're getting there right what we got what we looking at
What we looking at analizing the room that's looking good
Good for the most part
For the most part, but yeah that uh trapeze trapeze
Uh the prism that we got that album from that one band. I completely forgot the name of it
Again like the I don't want to pay money to roll these I'd rather just blow up the donation machine and spend it on angels
honestly, right so we are going to pop
Pop lock and drop it by uh
Doing that so now we already have two prisms
It oh god, I hate the eyes so much
They like laser beam attack and you have like zero time to respond. It's so annoying
But with how many
Drops we might be getting
I hate the ones on the wall as well. Oh and the ghosts as well. You know what?
I just I just struggle with a lot of isic enemies. You know what? I'll admit my weak points
I'm just bad at the game. I just get very lucky with my drops
But yes as you oh my god, lunch it was a two percent drop for lunch
No way it was a two percent drop for lunch. Can you can you come out already? Geez you are hiding bro
You're quivering
Is he for real? Is he the only enemy in the room? Ah, right? Okay
Uh two percent
Bro the streamer luck. Sorry. I've never had such good isic. I wonder I've not played the game in like over a month
Is it possible the game like detects?
Fuuuuck you know is it possible the game can detect have not played in a while and is like uh
Game odds make this person addicted to isic again
I don't know if that's a thing. I mean it could be if you wanted it to be
Oh my god the homing
Oh
Not those homing bombs the other kind of hoping
Ah just
Do you see the bottom stat that says 66
Angel and we and we get devil grove. I'm not risking my health. Sorry. I'm not I'm not risking my health
Right, we've got a golden key, which means we get a free pair
Yeah
If this drops yara rune it is over
If this drops yara rune it is over yara duplicates all items that are on the floor
I'm going to pop temperance as well. I'm going to use that on this floor
It it is over
I'm going to pop temperance uh on purpose. I'm going to pop it inside the shop. I'm right
Right
I'm gonna pick that up. I'm gonna do that and then I'm gonna tap down to two
No, no pay out. Are you not feeling it buddy? Come on
I'm so mommy
What is this flight for the room? Okay curious curious don't need it but curious nonetheless
Oh
What is going on?
What is going on we now have counterfeit penny which every time we pick up one coin we have a chance to double it
What is can the game detect I've not played in a while because what wait why
What
What are you got for me troll bombs? No, thank you
Uh, maybe a crawl space
We just broke something. I heard that
Did we break something?
Um, it's gonna be worth their money. I'm not gonna put it down any further
There we go black. Yeah. Yeah. Okay. I see. I see. I see. I see. I see. Okay
We've got the hanged man something broke in here. I heard it when we use that room chart
Keep money for the angel
Man, you're so right me once
I will not be tempted I will not be tempted
Although I have five bombs so I'm just gonna blow him up in case he has a chance
Oh, we can get it we can do a tears up and two so hearts
I'm going I'm coming
I can't believe the streamer luck. What is this?
What is the streamer log? I can't believe it
Oh, come on we lily
I'm ready to have a heart attack out of excitement
Right don't
Oh
Hell is that it?
I'm actually not that interested but I'm interested in blowing you up to fuck me
Do we want to I don't really want to
I
Stone at the top one guys. What did I miss? Yeah, Edmund person that showed up in my house when I stopped for a year
Oh Edmund personally showed up at my house and stopped
Yeah, I'm not really fussed. I might give
I might give some of my money to to the beggar honestly
Right, we're gonna bomb because we have one in three chance for a soul here
Well, I used up all my streamer luck. I'm gonna give some money to the judgment. Normally he gives us a good little
Uh, we already have mother which is a shame. Um, but hey hope
Right, we've got a maculic conception and now we will leave. Thank you
Now we can go straight into here
We may get conjoined
Oh my god, just say you love me game
Just say you personally love me. It's fine. Oh and another one of these come on, baby
Just say you love me
Just say it game
Right, we're gonna use the hanged man because there's not really gonna be any opportunity to use it for anything else to be honest
Oh
As if that didn't drop anything range or range is fine
This is insane
What the hell is happening? Uh, I'm getting extremely lucky to the point where my chair is wet
This is just by far insane
Streamer luck that you're seeing in 4k
Um, it is beyond comprehension
How insane I'm gonna purposely try not pick anything up because if we drop a yara rune
I see skinny runes being dropped. I'm asking politely for a yara rune. I don't spot one
I don't spot a yara
I don't spot one
Maybe next time maybe next time maybe next time
Okay
Okay, one more fight one more fight. I can I'm trying so hard not to pick up anything. Oh, it's that yara
I'm fucking coming. I'm coming right. We need to do the angel first though
What are you seraphim double tapping creates a shield sure?
Oh my god, we have yara
Oh
Yara duplicates all pickups in the room. Well, I am
Don't mind if I do
Talk about streamer luck. Holy moly
A bit of streamer luck don't mind if I do. Uh, I'm probably not actually oh my god. Oh
My yeah
We oh, we have so much we have so much we need to go spend
Please right. We don't need range. We don't need that. Let's do what we're not going to do chaos
We're not going to do that either. Jeez. Uh, I mean an orbital for defense really isn't that bad. We can swallow trinkets
Is that no am I done I did I buy the wrong thing possibly
We could buy a card pack and the chance that we get two
Times two money on hand
doubles my bombs
Yes, please I will make sure I have 50 in my inventory. Thank you. Oh my god. What is going on?
What is going on actually hacks right now? I'm not being funny, but actually hacks
Uh
Attracts coins. No, I don't need that
range
No, we don't need range
We'll take any of this stuff
More damage
for me
Oh, you shouldn't have game. You're so nice to me
Do it again and keep doing it. I'm gonna come
Every 30 seconds drops a battery for max pair
to in the room
You want that? I think we want that
No, we are not using plan c before anyone says plan c shite bag if you didn't
Uh, sure. We'll take another
I've got another orbital if we want protection high priestess. I'm going to check what's in the bottom room
Let me just pick up the rest of these real quick
Um, we do have a chance for a crawl space with these guys. So use them on the diamond. Uh, there you go
Just like that. Uh, any any image tail
Do we
Homing homing lasers
Homing laser beam
Oh, we have met uh homing laser beam. So we're going to take this rune shard to the next floor
Homing
Uh
This cannot be
Is this what the children refer to as streamer luck? Now, we're gonna just pick up the bandage because why not?
Were you shot speed and health? No, thank you
This can't I'm literally hacking the the code is called
A h a a 3g to tango
Come on. Oh my god
Uh, I don't want black hole the one that let's try and I oh
Oops, I can't get the angel angel deal now. Oh well
The bells of heaven are ringing
What the fuck is this dreamer look every time we now activate we double or we double on uh like on top like
brov
What is going on?
Right, we have bombs. We're gonna bomb the machine. Hopefully we can get a fiverr back. Uh, I doubt it, but hey ho
You never know
We got our penny back
Um, right. We're good to go. We've got counterfeit penny
Life is good and we have freaking yara
I'm making sure to avoid that with all my life
And I definitely picked up the items from the room because I forget all the time to pick up the items
But I'm just making double sure right, okay
This is rng the greatest rng to ever rng. Yes again the room code for this greed is
alpha hotel alpha alpha 3 juliet 2 tango
Okay, we're taking yara to the night floor
And before another yara, okay, this is now the last ah sugar
I should have
Oh, that would have actually been a bit juicy. I have to admit it's a damage up. Um, like it is what it is
It is what it is
Uh judgment. I'm so sorry to do this to you mate, but
There is no hope
Right you and go
Okay
Okay, let's see what the shop has to offer off the oh, wow
Whatever, uh, oh no should have left on the floor. Okay. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine
Okay, let's clear out this area see if there's anything of interest
Uh off the bat not rng yara. Maybe bomb these guys see what's up
And this was a
What does 19 do
Taking damage as a span chance to spawn something not really fuss for that. Uh, we will cycle to the next just to see what's up
We might be able to get a spun duplicate two random pickups in the room
Curious
Uh, right yara. We do not want to pick up anything. Is this run even a challenge? No
And that's the best part about isaac when you break the game
Because the game wants you to suffer the game wants you to cry and give up
So when you break the game because of how kind it's been. Oh, wow, we're unlocking super meat boy
I didn't realize you do that that laughter meant there's a hand going to come down
Yeah, like that. I'm trying not to pick up anything. I really am I'm trying got out something got me. I don't know what got me
I'm
Again with the hands. Hold on. I really am trying not to pick up a single thing in this room, but they're getting pushed around
Oh, goodness, ruby. I can't
I can't even see
Okay
Okay, just gently easy. Let's kill the bosses nice and quick nice and quick
Nice and quickly now. Don't pick anything up in this room
Okay, one more time one more time
Uh
Ow
Okay, okay easy easy just just edge ourselves gently
Oh my god. Crap. Well taking a pipspun a white poop
Or a seraphim two soul hearts flight chargeable. Holy beans does not replace tears. Wow
Oh, wowie we wow
Revelation right gently easy easy
Okay, duplicate everything and then we're going to look to see if there's an extra era just for the
Unlucky we've got full health on the sun. So let's pop that
And then we're going to grab oh the sun again
Of course, it was going to be the sun again because we uh did a thing called duplication. You dumb dumb
Roon shard. What did that do? Roon shard
Okay, we're gonna just do a little investigation on our our wares or trinkets
Unlucky room full ago. I know I guess there is another era though
Okay, let's go spend some of this goodness. We're gonna go to short speed
We don't really need luck although that gives us a soul heart and
Oh, no, I'm already full. Okay, let's spin. Wait, there might be a secret here
No, it must be down
Uh, we don't really need any of this
Can we duplicate spider baby? That would be cute. Oh sure. Oh wait. No, that was silly. Okay taking damage of this goods
Sponsor sack. I mean we're at the end of the game anyway. We don't really need it
Yeah, let's see what else we've got. We've got fun guy
I mean, what's underneath fun guy? We won. Oh, we got spun. We got spun feels good, man
Okay, let's uh
Wait, didn't I not bomb that or am I going crazy?
This is why Lilith is so broken in greed mode honestly
so
Are you fucking serious right now, right? Anyway, it's fine. It's fine. It's fine. It's fine
I'm not mad
I'm not mad. I'm not mad. Okay. I'm not mad. I'm not raging. I'm not absolutely raging
I didn't even know the runes could do that to be honest. Oh home in tears as if I need it as if I need it
Right, I'll pick it up already. I mean I can Yara this room room, I guess
Yara
Give me my pennies
right
What can we can buy four more items as long as the restock machine? We don't need health now
As long as this doesn't blow up
What?
Okay, my only exception of going in here is for yeah, oh first wrong one. Oh, that's a bomb
Oh, we got gupsters
Oh, we got one gupsters
Yeah
And then we go pick up immaculate conception again
Active item can be overcharged if only you showed up a bit earlier right we'll take halo. That's a massive upgrade. Um
I mean, we've only got enough money for two more
Range on tapeworm. Why would the tapeworm give you range? Honestly, and then just bomb it because we've not got enough for anything else
Uh, oh, that's a shame. Uh, that's rubbish. Right. Uh, let's let's go
Um full health. We'll take it just in case but I'm not really too worried and as we take damage
We actually can spawn in more of the goodness
So we got guppy a wee bit of guppy, but that's fine
Now she finds sacred heart discounted to
Oh, literally
Oh, wait, there's another level to this
Oh
rubbish
Wait, how did you predict that? I would get sacred heart spawned in again
That the game literally said I'll be nice to you. That's funny though. It's okay though. Oh, there
Are sure the judgment why not?
Can't really do anything else with more money. So here you go buddy. All yours
I only have 15 coins. Don't be greedy now
I have the stars. Yeah, I'm not sure the
Hey, I only I only have three coins judgment. You're supposed to have an increased drop rate. Yeah, okay
Well, it is what it is
Okay, now there's normally we enemy in here. I'm not gonna pop my active for this room. That's just not worthy at all
Um
Can bomb the I mean it doesn't really do anything at this point
It's just the instant like
Uh
I don't know
Now we can purposely hurt ourselves
To get because we have nuns habit
If we purposely hurt ourselves, we can get charged and then that's another
Like batch of guys in to do damage. This is ridiculous
But as you can see, um
Lilith is a wee bit broken in greed mode. We literally aren't even fighting. He's not even near us
And we're just mowing this poor guy down
Like
We're not even
We no wild card necessary in this run
Oh my god, and we're dropping charges. We might actually get another
um
Chart if someone drops the chart, uh, you we could get another go out. I mean, it's done for honestly
It's done for
He he he
But yeah, that is greed mode
And I'm just pop it again so we can have another duplicate of everyone look at my gang
Look at my gang. My gang is amazing. This I've already done 99
20% jam rate as you can see I enjoy playing Lilith a lot in greed mode because you see the 20 percent jam rate
That means that machine is all fed by her and no one else
Um, that was a bad jam rate. But yes, that is greed mode. That is Isaac is a fantastic game
I cannot praise it enough. Um
You will lose so many hours in this. Why no phase two. We were not playing greedier mode
Greedier mode is a lot different than greed mode. I am not that strong in
Greedier mode
Oh, you remember that
um
That was complete streamer
Um rng complete streamer rng. That was insane. Um
I cannot believe that. I truly cannot believe that. Well, you play Isaac more and I mean in other streams. Yes in november
I'll be playing it with you
Um
But yes, this game has like an insane amount of items
Like in com in combinations you can do and as you can see an elite gamer like myself
Still hasn't unlocked everything yet. Look, I've still not unlocked everything and I have like hundreds of hours in this game
Um, but yeah, there's like look see look tons of stuff. I haven't unlocked
Eh, there's so all these items you unlock by playing the game
I
How fast it's doable to I'm not even fighting him absolute Chad menace
But yeah, as you can see a lot on the the last stuff not unlocked
Bloody guts
Lusty blood
Does he fuck?
Fuck his ass
But yeah, um
Absolutely fantastic game. Uh, you know make or break your run come. It's it's
Insanity the game started with, um
Ignore the death counter
Ignore the best street counter while you're at it as well
um
It's just I cannot praise the game enough. Um
You know, there's tons of endings in the game
Well, I'll show you the true ending
That makes me very sad, but this is a true ending
His mother mourning the loss
He saw his father leaving them without turning to say goodbye
He saw his mother sleeping and his father taking money from her purse
He heard the late night fights they had that kept him up at night and the guilt
He felt for what he believed he was causing
He felt the pain in his stomach during those sleepless nights
And saw his shadow in the closet waiting for him
As he rose he felt his fears drop
I cried so hard the first time as he became lighter his ascent became faster
He saw his one true companion alive
He saw his mother and father together again holding each other
He felt his mother kissing him on the head after he had said his prayers
And the comfort in knowing someone was watching over him
He saw his own birth and the faces of his parents filled with joy and optimism
And then
He saw nothing
Are you sure this is how you want this story to end Isaac?
You're the one writing it. It doesn't have to end this way
Here
How about we tell it a different way?
Maybe a happy ending
Good
Are you getting sleepy yet?
Yeah
Okay, so
Isaac and his parents lived in a small house and that's the start of the that's the opening of the game
So that ending a lot of people misinterpret it
a certain way
But Ed McMuffin has confirmed multiple times that yes, Isaac dies in the chest. He is a dead five-year-old in a chest
The ending people couldn't make heads or tails of because that male voice
Male on stream and that male voice you hear is his dad annunciate in the game. Okay
But the reason I want to point it out to you is because
Isaac has been
You know, he's got religious trauma. So he's being told
If i'm a good boy, I go to heaven all my fears go away
So as he's in his final moments as he slips away
In his head after defeating all these enemies these endless waves of bosses. He's done everything he possibly could
he feels
the fear
and
The guilt just melt off his body as he finally slips
And passes away inside the chest. He can see that third perspective of his mum finding him
He can see that third perspective of him watching over because um
In the male in the dad's voice he goes
Are you sure you want this story to end this way Isaac and Isaac says? Yes. I want it to be over
I want it to be why did you show us this because people can't figure out what the ending means and i'm gonna mention it
I'm gonna mention it in my little review and be like, why is this open to interpretation? It's very clear
If if Ed McMuffin goes
Isaac perishes
Everyone's like oh, but the fight the fight. He's away in heaven. No Isaac perished. He's been taught about heaven
This entire game is about being taught religion dogma all this stuff
he
Thinks he's going to heaven in his last moments
He feels no guilt because he's done everything this entire thing is in his head. He is in a chest
Adroni, Adroni explains the Bible
Sorry, I'm like clapping me hands. I'm like, who do she wants this to be to breath right delirium ending is that ending 21?
19 is delirium
No, this is the mother fight
in 20
So
Is this still this isn't delirium
Are you sure these three are hand clapping
Why are you just drawing the game for me close the game's been out for 10 years?
It's the 10 year anniversary this year. Do don't come here being like you're running the game 10 years this game's been out for
You're not coming to me being like no you've given me spoilers. No, I'm not having that
10 years you've had a you've had a deck aid
A deck aid
So this is what happens dies. This is his wee body
He's no longer missing because we found him
You haven't finished a single run in this game that's different
I was five seconds from getting this ending now it's ruined. Yeah. Well, you know what else is ruined open your mouth
I'm gonna fart in it
Now your taste buds are ruined
I
Can't believe strong we just spoiled the game like that a game that's been out for a decade
Yes, um, I am going to absolutely go ham reviewing this game. I'm reviewing Assassin's Creed Brotherhood. I'm a reviewing Isaac
I'm actually doing call to the lamb which is probably my newest 10 out of 10
um
Out of respect for the development team
I'm not allowed to review Elden Ring because I don't play it the way it's intended
But if I could I would I would say it's a 10 out of 10 if they implemented multiplayer the way people would like it
What will she ruin next first mix? So now Isaac. Oh, I can't believe it
Out of respect for the dev team, bro. I do not play I uh
Elden Ring
In any way shape or form of what the dev team announced that
Uh, we intended it to be like right now
Oh, I just got an achievement. It says yellow baby unlocked and caught. Don't mind if I do
Uh, we are gonna redirect
into
sheepsters
If she's uh
If she's uh, if she's uh, no, we're not because I'm freaking logged out. Holy crap. Wait. Why am I?
I'm logged out of youtube so hold on. I might have to go to my other fucking pc from are you serious?
and
hold on
Actually, I do have something to show you though
But yeah, as you can see I do not even have an even start one two sheep
Uh, I do have something to show you
Which is this is the version I can show you on youtube
But it doesn't put much to
mind uh, what the
Uh, you know, you know, you don't want to try stuff
For the content for the content
That goes on patreon if anyone
Supports me on patreon. I do have a uh, this the agendination. Okay, so, uh, here's the um
Uh
Uh, here's the appropriate. Uh, so who's gonna lose first? We're just playing a video game together
You know first person to lose at isak, you know
Uh
Beer and work. Yep
Yep, uh tofu teacher lets you pass the class if you
Uh
Roommate instructs you to help with arriving at your destination early
So if you're an early destination arriver, I may or may not
Have an audio about that
Uh, yes, uh, uh as for tofu
I wouldn't it be nice if I had an attachment. Hmm. Yes a tofu
Tofu attachment. Hmm. Okay curious
Curious, um, yes. Yes, your gps is broken so your roommate has to give you direction
Oh
Um
Which is that's back
I am going to happily redirect into sheepsters if she's up
She's not there's no other violor girl up right now
Uh
An emmy's away. Okay. Um, she had to end early. Oh, she pushed it back. Wait
She be cotton bomb. Have you done your stream today? I don't know. Hold on. She said she'll come back. We'll leave her
Uh, hold on me. Let me let me let me put one
Um
She be ended early restarting in one and a half hours. Okay, that's a bit late because I'm actually
For members for members of the channel. We're about to watch iron man. I need to go for a fat shit
I'm not even joking. Um, I am in agony holding in a fart right now
Um, I'm not even I don't even know there's not a point in pretending otherwise
We are going to return the favor to serenity
Serenity has been a fantastic friend of mercy and she's redirected into me a couple of times. Please
Be very kind to serenity
She has shown us nothing but kindness and she owes us nothing and yet has poured her heart out to violor
So please I urge you to give a very nice. Hello to serenity on my behalf
I will speak in the chat momentarily just so i'm not running and ditching
um, and uh
If I can pull up her channel, please. Why does it do that? Honestly?
Um, but yeah speaking of tarot cards, she's one of them
She's kind of playing sonic adventures a little nerd
and
The fingers
Okay, please be very nice to serenity. She's being fantastic and I will see
Members for some iron man very shortly. Please do give me 10 minutes. I'm going to get some food. I'm going to go for
You already know and I'm going to get a cup of tea. Um, so please enjoy serenity to your heart's content
Thank you so much for letting me neared out about Isaac as well. This game means a lot to me in terms of
I played it a lot whilst um violor was in production. So I felt quite
I don't know. It's just one of those things where I will always associate the game with just having a hoot and holler
Um
And all that jazz. Anyway, thank you so much. We feelings. I'll see you shortly if you're a member or if not, please don't worry
I'm streaming every single day. Um, I will put up my streams
after
A cheeky bit of iron man and you'll be able to see what's coming up for the week
I am doing a bit of shorter streams, but that's because I have very fantastic news coming out soon
There is a lot of exciting things. I cannot say yet, but I believe in the next 40 hours
There should be something very um fun that I will review on stream. That is public access. Um
There's also uh another thing. You know what? There's a lot of things. Okay. Um
But yes, thank you so so much for letting me know about Isaac
I am more than happy to play the game again at a later day even before november
Um, if you guys really enjoyed that because I
Streamer luck is real. That was insane. Yerra runes out the wazoo
Spawned in with a wafer on eden is just insanity in itself. Thank you so so much game reveal game reveal not yet
Later the month. Uh, it may be at the end of the month. It may be at the start of august
I'll keep you up to date. Um with the actual violour game itself. Um, but thank you so so much
Please enjoy serenity to the heart's content. Thank you for letting me nerd out and I will see your cutie bitoody very shortly
Thank you
Be good
Wait, wait, pucker pucker your lips right now go
Bye replaying see you shortly. See you later. I'll gear in a while
I'll do a replaying version of that soon, but
See you soon. Bye